David small illustrator
that's thrilling I'm I'm you know
overwhelmed but I've I also I've won a
big award and a couple of minor things
and I I'm trying to just keep in mind
that this is just a blip you know in my
life I mean if I get it that'll be very
nice and probably lead to a flurry of
emails and phone calls and who knows
maybe some trips and then it'll all be
over and the big spotlight will move on
to somebody else and my studio will
become very quiet again and it's that's
that's just the way it goes and that's a
good thing
do not believe that it was
miscategorized I think it was
categorized exactly where it should be I
I didn't think of categories when I was
writing the book I knew that I was
stepping out of the children's world but
I never thought that I was stepping
completely into the adult world because
the book is about a teenager for example
it really the principal ages are 6 and
14 of the main character and I women
when the controversy started I began
having second thoughts and wondering
hmmm that I put some things in there
that you know teenagers couldn't handle
I didn't think so
I mean they see so much now and things
are talked about so openly and in young
adult literature I actually thought that
I was being rather modest
in my book with the things that I left
out and also by not taking by not
adopting a totally sarcastic viewpoint
that I questioned myself about that too
because it had almost seemed totally
uncool to to not be you know absolutely
ironic about everything I I'm not really
ironic about anything in this book it's
pretty sincere without I hope ever
falling into sentimentality which I
despise but I I you know I was
questioning it until yesterday at the
New York Public Library where the five
of us finalists spoke to a room of I
don't know it looked like hundreds of
teenagers and they all came up to the
mics afterwards with questions and I
could see that these young people were
so touched by stitches I was there was
just unbelievable it was the questions
that they asked were they were the equal
of the very best questions that I have
been asked by bloggers in the whole you
know you can read 53 pages of
blogs and reviews of my book on Google
and and these kids were just as
intelligent and just as they were giving
my book just as sensitive a read as any
adult who's talked to me and I I was
really touched by that and as one of the
teachers said to me who came up to the
table afterwards you know everybody
feels especially at this age they feel
the kind of isolation that that's talked
about in stitches they feel that that
kind of loneliness and I you know the
book is really it's not about it is not
about being an abused child in the sense
of the kind of abuse that attracts our
attention in newspapers all the time you
know kids getting their limbs broken and
being thrown downstairs are out of
second-floor windows that none of that
happened to me I was abused but it was
all psychological
it was much subtler and I think everyone
to some extent can relate to that and I
think above all why this is a book for
teenagers is that teenagers part of the
teenage angst part of the part of the
Hoxton us of being a teenager and part
of the rebellion is that this sense that
they're not being told everything about
the adult world that there's a that
there's a deep hypocrisy out there that
they are desperate to know about and you
know teenagers they're always sneaking
around in drawers where they shouldn't
go and reading things they shouldn't be
reading and and that's an attempt to try
I think to penetrate and that actually
happens in my book there's that's how I
found out as a teenager what was going
on boy was by sneaking into drawers and
reading letters that I had no business
reading this is how I found out that I
had had cancer that everybody my whole
family thought that I was going to die
and nobody had told me about it
and my reaction at the time was the
reaction that I had been taught by my
own family to give which was to clam up
to not respond to hold it inside and
then when I started like a teenager will
to act out and in pretty bad ways
running away from school and threatening
suicide and needing to see a shrink and
so on that's when that's when the truth
began to come out and and of course what
I discovered on my own was that you know
that I'd had cancer but then I found out
later that it was my dad who had given
it to me as in his in his practice as a
radiologist and and that was just the
sort of the tip of the iceberg in terms
of mixed metaphors family skeletons you
know that was the least of the ones that
came tumbling out of the closet one
after another at that point so I think
this is something that kids really
really can relate to and I don't see it
miscategorized it on and very happy to
be in that category
you know I I've been around I've been in
that flurry of whatever terminology
misunderstanding I I'm perfectly fine
with the term graphic graphic books you
know where they refers to fiction or
memoir or or what-have-you it doesn't it
doesn't bother me I'm not a I'm not a
purist about comics or anything like
that maybe because I never really
followed comics and I don't know much
about that world I don't know much about
the graphic novel world either I wasn't
a big fan of them until until I read
some of the European things and and now
and then of course somebody started
sending me piles of them when they when
they heard that what that I was working
on my own I started receiving some but I
didn't read any of them until I was
finished with my book because I didn't
want to be infected or influenced yeah I
especially didn't want to see anything
that was really tremendous they would
make me feel intimidated so I guess this
is a twisted way of telling you that I
really didn't know what I was doing
except telling my story in the bed in
the way the best way I thought I could
but I know there's a I know there is a
there's a big insistence on people from
the comics world it's it's as as if they
want to get their due finally they want
to be respected and so they keep
insisting that these things be called
comics and you know if they want to call
my book a comic book about my life
that's fine too I don't care it is in
panels but I don't use many of the comic
book conventions my influences are more
from film and certain films certain film
makers
type I'm a
like I I have a great reader I I keep
going back though to certain authors
just like I love film but I keep going
back to certain just five or six certain
filmmakers in literature I like check
off for example I think he's my favorite
and and flow bear you know that kind of
concision but I also like Tolstoy I love
those romances that you know weigh 500
pounds and take months and months months
to read I read all of the I read the
three big novels of Thomas Mann in one
year that was a that was an interesting
project but I'd found that like check
off you have to read him as if he's a
short story writer and are in order to
get through those novels in film I like
the guys that came along in the 60s and
early 70s along from Europe Bunn well
and Polanski and Bergman antonioni I
didn't like very much when I first saw
him but now later on realizing that even
though I found his movies very boring
when I was in college and sort of
incomprehensible or it's converse kind
of insult too easy to understand going
back to them I went I have gone back to
them recently because I realized that
some of his his images and sequences
were unforgettable I couldn't get them
enough out of my mind so it was good to
go back as an adult and to see them and
I think certain of his films are just
works of genius so it was early things
and I like the people that those people
were influenced by Welles and Hitchcock
and they of course were influenced by
silent film but I don't know much about
that medium
odd it started as an act of self therapy
really I found that I had reached over
half a century of life and and that I
was still in spite of the fact that I
have a perfect career doing something I
really love to do a wonderful home a
wonderful wonderful marriage friendship
and in spite of all of these things I
was having dreams and sometimes
anxieties and exhibiting a kind of
erratic behavior that showed quite
clearly that I was still on some level a
troubled lad of 14 or even younger and I
had always wanted to write
maybe stories or something relating to
some things that had happened to me as a
young man but I I never thought there
was a full memoir or even a possibility
of a book in there but I but I did have
this need to go back and to see my youth
again what I really wanted was I really
wanted to go back into psychoanalysis I
had had a wonderful analyst he's in the
book for 12 years when I was a young man
but I wouldn't call it I wouldn't call
it deep Freudian analysis because I was
so young my analysis really was going to
an office first five and then three
times a week for many years and sitting
down with a man who actually was for me
a perfect parent somebody who just
allowed me to be myself who loved me for
who I was and just allowed and he really
did love me I think that's why it was so
effective he he really cared for me and
because I had no voice he had to speak
for me
so the talking cure in my case got
reversed it was the analyst who did all
the talking telling me what was probably
he thought going on in
and as it turned out many years later
because of the similarity merit ease in
our experience he did understand me very
very well but you know being able to sit
with somebody and who was who was
patient with me and sympathetic and
empathetic and who would allow me to act
out my fears and and so on and who
didn't despise me for it you know that
was that's really what saved me as a
young man and I wanted that back I
wanted to do it again yeah you know I
was I think fifty five maybe ten years
ago when I first started longing to go
back okay and they also I wanted it back
fully I didn't want to just be going to
see a therapist and you know I wanted
that kind of relationship but the fact
is I live on the edge of a Prairie out
in Michigan you know we're very rural
setting hundreds and hundreds of miles
from that kind of help I'm not even sure
I have health insurance that would cover
it and so I finally realized after
yearning for it for so long this
impossible thing that I was if I was
gonna have it I was really gonna have to
give it to myself and that's what I did
I started sitting down and first in
prose and then later on in pictures
tried to write out what had happened to
me as a kid and I tried to imitate what
my old analysts have done for me I was
patient as I worked through all this
mess of memories which of course came
back with no you know memories aren't
chronological they didn't come back in
any logical order but I just let that
happen I let it flow if I had dreams
that I had that I if I suffered from a
dream that disturbed me at the time I
would write it down as I usually do and
try to and and then to draw it out
when when it started becoming a graphic
thing and so I was I was trying to be
like my my doctor I was trying to be
patient and sympathetic and yet not not
totally tolerant you know there was
always an expectation that I would get
through this and and then later on when
I had a contract from a publisher that
was that was another spur to to get
through it to get to the end and that's
the way it developed that's the way it
started it didn't really start as a book
it started as therapy
I think the worst thing the worst part
was when I started drawing things out
they really got real for me as long as I
was doing it in prose there would there
seem to be kind of a scrim between me
and the experiences that I was
remembering shadows moving behind an
opaque screen but when I began to draw
especially my mother when I saw her face
on the page and when I realized that I
could draw her from any angle and really
brought her back with all of her with
that aura that she had I It was as if
she was with me again there was as if I
had really brought the ghosts back and I
began to get very very anxious because
it even after the age of 50 it was
impossible for me to see my mother as a
human being I felt she was a monster and
she had suddenly been influencing my
behavior and my thoughts and my dreams
for so long that she was kind of a
monster she was a demon and when I
brought her back to life I could feel
that malevolent presence around me again
that that that woman who was totally
incapable of giving nurturing to anybody
and you know her selfishness and her her
her withdrawn indifference to everything
but her own needs and and I began
feeling these feelings of anxiety that I
used to have when she was alive and
especially when I was a teenager and one
night my wife and I were out at a
restaurant and and I was waiting in my
face like this around my neck and I
suddenly could feel this lump swelling
up under my fingers and I thought at
first that it was just some sort of
physical Colusa nation until I looked at
my wife and she'd just gone white she
reached across the table and took my
wrist and she said darlin what's wrong
and I said I don't know
and she thrusts a glass of wine into my
hands and said drink this and I drink it
and to calm me down a little bit but I
could actually feel that this lump was
there it was hard and it was it was big
and growing and it was exactly like this
lump that I had had in my neck when I
was 14 that had taken years and years to
get to the size of a like an eggplant
but here it had come back in a matter of
minutes and I stumbled into the men's
room which thank God was empty and I had
to see it in the mirror because I had to
see what was happening to me and there
indeed again was this lump that I had
had which was of course cancerous when I
was 14 and I realized that at that
moment that my body was expressing all
of my repent repressed feelings and all
of my all of my anger and anxiety since
I wasn't letting it out since I wasn't
able to speak about it my body was
speaking for me and I understood at that
moment in that place that awful little
room that I could die from it if I
didn't do something about it that that
that it was gonna kill me and it could
have happened right there and so I just
took some deep breaths and I said this
is not where I'm gonna die and this is
not the end and I'm going to do
something about this and it was that
moment that I resolved to seriously get
to work on this book and the lump of
course turned out to be a swollen gland
it went right down that same hour it
just went away just disappeared
solutely yeah no doubt about it and that
you know that humanization and that I'm
coming to understand somebody as a human
being is about as good kind of
forgiveness as you can get I think I
don't like my parents I never will I
didn't cry at either of their funerals I
haven't missed them for five seconds I
didn't you know our characters were so
at odds with one another right from the
beginning but I do understand them now
as human beings with the understanding
of an adult as a man I can now having
seen them again and brought them back
having you know furnished the rooms and
let the ghosts come in and hack their
little plays again I've been able to see
them and understand their impulses their
fears their fears of having no money in
the case of my mother you know that's an
adult thing or hidden sexuality you know
sexual impulses that you don't want to
bring out that's an adult thing children
don't understand this joke you know as a
six-year-old and my brother we we just
the two of us could not understand what
was going on in our household and I
don't think any kid really can until
they're adults they just they're just
certain things you can't talk about with
kids I just totally do not believe in
this kind of Bart Simpson character who
infects so many of so much of our
literature and film and TV stuff
nowadays these know-it-all kids who seem
to understand the hypocrisy of the adult
world so thoroughly and can talk about
it with such articulate nasarah scence
they really are for a long time no
matter what they see no matter what
they're exposed to they can't get it
until they have developed enough
I began drawing probably
around the same time everybody else puts
a mark on a piece of paper or the Korean
when I was - probably the difference
between me and everybody else is I kept
doing it for the rest of my life there
was something very satisfying about that
and I also got a lot of praise from it
for it from my mother and her friends
and so on because this was the early 50s
and you know that was before the days of
TV before the days of women in the
workforce and anything that distracted a
child and and took him off in a safe way
and out of the mother's hands was
praiseworthy and that's what drawing I'm
sure you know my mother thought it was
just great that I would draw endlessly
for hours and and my dad actually
furnished my first art materials
straight out of the x-ray department at
the hospital where he worked the first
drawing paper I ever worked on were
these enormous sheets of yellow paper
from the Kodak company that used to come
wrapped around x-ray films instead of
throwing that wet stuff away every week
they started boxing it up for David and
they'd bring it home on Friday nights my
dad would come home with a new box of
yellow x-ray paper and I'd get out my
crayons and draw on the living room
floor just endlessly but I never wanted
to be an artist I wanted when I started
thinking about a career in the arts it
was more literature or for a while I was
acting I don't know if I ever would have
developed into a good actor but that got
completely sketched when I lost my vocal
cord at 14 and that operation but
writing always writing plays writing
writing writing that was what I wanted
to do and I actually had some plays put
on in Detroit when I was 17 that was
back in the sixties when there was all
kind of kinds of experimental theater
theaters
popping up everywhere and Detroit was no
different from any other cultural center
they had little professional theaters in
storefronts and so on and and my plays
were picked by one of them to be put on
and
the university put on another one and
then a and then a friend of mine one
night who was he was a really wonderful
photographer so I listened to his
opinion he came to me and he did me the
favor of telling me the truth which is
very hard he had to get a little drunk
to do it but he said David I got to tell
you man
I've been your roommate for two years
I've watched you writing away every day
and I've seen all your plays put on and
you've let me read all of these things
and quite frankly I I don't know why
you're not studying art because the
little doodles that you make on the pad
by the phone are so much better than
anything you ever wrote
they just seem to flow from you so much
more naturally and easily I think that's
what you should be doing and I was
furious with him for you know a couple
of hours but then I began to realize
that this huge weight had been lifted
off my neck that I didn't have to
pretend that I was a writer anymore
because it wasn't there was the kid that
I wasn't a writer it was the hardest
thing I've ever done was try to write
plays or to finish them was a real feat
and it left me exhausted not exhilarated
but art I had never thought of that as a
career because it was like something I
did so naturally and it was fluid and it
is and even though I still admire
literature as the superior art form I I
have to admit that art for me that's
that's it that's what I'm good at and
that's what I should be concentrating
that
artist the artist of the month you know
I used I just when I was your age I was
I was just letting myself be totally
immersed in first
domi a Lautrec I loved you know both
guys they have things in common not just
that they're French but that their
drawings are filled with life and then
later on it came to appreciate a guy who
whose drawings are very measured and
very exacting and yet still have this
feeling of life coming out of them
and again Sheila but I also like the
expressionist I loved some of Kokoschka
stuff and and Rembrandt above all I
think Rembrandt is drawings not so much
the paintings but that those wonderful
loose brush drawings that were obviously
done very quickly and with so much
knowledge of anatomy and structure
underneath them but that just in a few
lines just dashed off the whole scene
the whole expression of the body there
and then you know that plus studying
Anatomy when I got into college
things like anatomy and drawing and
design and color had pretty much been
dropped kicked out of the curriculum in
the 70s when I was studying art in favor
of abstraction and minimalism and you
know people had basically thrown up
their hands with storytelling in art in
those days and said heart is pointless
so let's just make it a skin of paint on
the canvas and do that in a pretty way
and here I wanted to learn to draw the
figure from any angle in any position
from memory and so I I I studied that
and thank God found a few teachers that
were still interested in teaching it
both at Wayne State in Detroit where I
did my undergraduate work and at Yale in
the grad school there
but then later on as a teacher I
continued I taught Anatomy I chose to
teach anatomy which nobody wanted to
study but I I wanted to teach it because
AI was enthusiastic about it and I knew
that I could make some kids interested
in it and I did but B I wanted to learn
more about it and you know so I was
always a couple steps ahead in my class
and it was good it was worthwhile
oh I do keep up at night I um I try not
to let my mind go go to two extremes in
the middle of the night because it'd be
better to turn all that stuff into
dreams it'd be better if I was sleeping
because dreams become good metaphors for
what's really going on inside of you but
you know I come from a family of my
mother worried about money all the time
and I think her being a Depression child
was part of that but that vision of hers
of always ending up in the poorhouse or
and or her kind of she never talked
about it but I'm sure she had
apocalyptic you know personal visions of
poverty and destitution that that have
infected me and they you know my brother
has the same ends anxieties and they're
silly really but but that's part of the
family tradition and I had something I
would hope to break sometime in my life
but I don't know if it's ever gonna go
away yeah I worry about money I worry
about security and nowadays it's really
easy to to fret about those that sort of
thing I try not to watch the news too
much because that just aggravates the
the anxiety